okay let's check out this video i think
it's interesting
people at home think about
would how would you feel
how would you feel if one of your
friends picked up the phone
and asked you if they could hook up with
your ex
this situation in the past where i was
dating this girl you're not gonna know
this girl i was dating this girl and we
had broken up i had a friend call me and
was like yo i'm out with i'm out with
your girl this was like months down the
line she's like i'm out with you know
this girl at this club and she's like
coming on to me and this friend asked me
do you mind i'm asking if i can hook up
with your ex-girlfriend like essentially
and truthfully it was hard for me at the
time to say that no i don't mind and i
don't know if it was like an ego thing
if i if i felt like i said yes i'd feel
like weak like my my connection to my ex
made me feel weak i said no i don't mind
if you hook up with her and then they
did hook up and it actually like hurt me
the next day i was like okay though this
would have been a great video actually
even for rolo to comment on because i'm
going to tell you straight the fact that
that guy said it hurt him
made
i was it appealed to me even more like i
liked him when he said that he went from
being like like that's the kind of guy
that i would have dated who would have
been willing to admit like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] hurt me so vulnerabilities in men
again you don't have to cry through
titanic every time it goes on a little
vulnerability a little showing like i
gave [ __ ] about that situation and like
it hurt that goes a long way we women we
eat that up like candy
all right
eric's in the room he's like wow judd
got a little too excited about that
vulnerability i don't know man i don't
know
because guys don't share it they don't
show that and if they do it's like it's
frowned upon you know and they don't
have to cry to show that they care but
like even that's like when he said it is
the same for me i'm like oh like you
know he felt something with this girl it
wasn't just like a banged her and i
dated her right exactly so now see
people in the manuscript are listening
it's a young girl i don't know if you're
dating anybody right now but let's just
say are you you want to share that or no
you don't have to
okay she don't want to share it all
right some people like their privacy who
knows but regardless of you know like
perfect age to be out there dating
experience saying again
that vulnerability in men doesn't have
to be excessive like no we don't want
you showing up crying every night for
the that's not that would be weird then
maybe some therapy or something i don't
know but you know a little bit of a sign
that you actually gave a [ __ ] because
also if you gave a [ __ ] about that girl
you're probably gonna give a [ __ ] about
the next girl like you're somebody who
gives a [ __ ] is the bottom line
awesome now let's talk about the x
situation now i'm again i'm not going to
say i got to stop saying i'm a relic i'm
21 too
anyway
i'm old school on this and i don't
understand like
when i was young like you just didn't do
this there was like girl code and there
was guy code and if it was an x now
unless it was somebody that say
he had gone out on a date with they
didn't sleep together wasn't serious
like they went out for a few hours
didn't work out wasn't a good match
that's different that's like whatever
they didn't have anything but an
ex-girlfriend to have your friend call
you up and be like do you mind if i hook
up with and i'm not sure what is hook up
in this are they talking about sex or
are they talking about whatever the
night leads to
say hook up i think it just depends on
the people like it depends like some
people are like
like to me hooking up is like your
any type of contact like that's hooking
up like kissing any of that okay but to
some people hooking up is like you all
the way all the way so it could be
either it could be upon you know
again like and also it might mean
different things in different parts of
the country too again i don't know it'd
be interesting to have i would love to
do a panel with people from different
parts of the country on dating and see
like
the difference their minds would be
blown by the show but this [ __ ] going on
in south beach is all i'm gonna say
but i am old school about this and i
can't imagine that like somebody you
dated like you're if if your friend
calls you and asked that i would like
have a little concern about that
friendship like dude why you put me on
the spot like that because now it's
uncomfortable to say no because then
you're like do i look like
i don't know insecure or weird or like i
still have feelings for that girl if i
say no
so in the heat of the moment you're just
like sure whatever because you want to
like play it off cool
but that's weird
but i think it's the difference between
guy and girls like a guy i mean like bro
can i hook up with this girl versus like
girls you know girls are a little more
territorial you know and like even when
they break up they may break up and have
feelings left behind sometimes guys like
they'll just be like yeah whatever you
know do you think so see i don't know i
think i think guys i think it's
different if it was a girl they really
liked like it depends also if it was a
girl that like you didn't care that much
about you dated for a few months it
wasn't a thing i don't think they'd care
if it was like a girlfriend but what if
it was a girlfriend they really cared
about and the girlfriend cheated on him
and then he was like can i look over
here and he's like go ahead bro like i
think guys are more okay with it girls
would be like why are you trying to hook
up with him i can tell you straight up
not only would girls
not be okay with it
but it would almost make you like that
guy again like
wait a minute
am i wrong you're right i don't know a
minute you're going to hook up wait a
minute start thinking about all the good
times you start romanticizing him you
remember that one night oh yeah he's
talking real well
you could smell his cologne wafting up
your nose again you're like
wait a minute
and then you call that girl the next day
you're like did you hook up with him
what happened
you want to know
she's like oh yeah you know we went out
we did x y z you're like
what exactly did you do with him you
want to know did they have sex you know
it then if they did you get off the
phone you call another friend and you're
like i can't believe what amy just said
like she slept with sam and sam was like
listen i'm over sam i'm over sam you
know that it's like i don't want him
anymore but did she need to do that and
why did he do it i mean i'm over him but
i still like i mean i did go out with
him there's it's always gonna be some
feeling there did he just totally forget
about what a douchebag you go in that
conversation from being back in love to
hate to back in love women are complex
creatures i think it's fomo you know
that fear of missing out and it's like
you moved on but then someone you know
they're like can i hook up with him and
you're like wait did he get better like
why do you want to go with him when i
was with him i didn't want to hook up
with him you know like what's the new
thing going on now so i i don't know and
i'm going to tell you something the
friendship will be changed if that
happens
i'm telling you
on either side i think i think it's true
for both unless the guy unless it's the
situation like this and the guy was it
was a girl that he didn't really care
about he was like whatever she cheated
on me or like i wasn't really into that
you know whatever
with girls
no matter what
that's that relationship will be changed
if you ask her if you ask your female
friend if you can help hook up with her
ex
things are different the fact that you
asked you are now you're not getting
that best friend necklace again if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]